halo hat sich willkommen in meiner
torkelt ich werde heute leckere
hähnchenspieße mit sidney machen und ich
bin hier gerade in meiner grill reihe
und das ist ein teil davon
ich habe schon ganz viele konzepte
gemacht und ich mache meine
hähnchenspieße immer ganz gern mit
seiner joghurt machen weil der joghurt
das hähnchenfleisch richtig schön weich
macht und das fleisch dann auch richtig
schön saftig ist und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal meine tod hatten
ich habe hier drei hühner brüste und wie
ihr sehen könnt ich da dass ihn viele
noch drin
ich habe hier einen esslöffel
naturjoghurt bessert das ist jetzt in 35
prozentiger eine kleine zwiebel habe ich
jetzt eine charlotte gewählt 2
knoblauchzehen schon geschehen
ein teelöffel tomatenmark könnte auch
paprika markt nehmen
ein teelöffel salz eine gute prise
pfeffer eine halbe zitrone davon den
saft und ich nehme noch zwei esslöffeln
olivenöl zuerst wehrte zwar mein fleisch
schneiden und nehmen dazu dass ihnen
viel lieber raus und schneit es einfach
in kleine stücke nicht zu klein und ob
das hier in eine kleine schüssel rein
so sieht des fleisches aus ist kann ich
kurz zur seite stellen
und wer hier jetzt meine marinade
vorbereiten ich mach das ist einfache
mixa könnte aber auch die zwiebeln und
den knoblauch einfach fein hacken und
alles miteinander vermischen
ich gebe jetzt auch den joghurt gleich
mit dazu die gewürze mache ich dann
gleich im anschluss
es gebe ich den rhein statt vorher ein
problem weil ich kann nächstes sogleich
das auch mit dazu
zitronensaft und olivenöl vermischen
schön miteinander und ist hinter spies
die mache ich gerne natürlich auf dem
grill aber wenn wir zum beispiel nicht
wählen geht es auch einfach in der
pfanne
also ich bereite die spieße auch ganz
gerne der pfanne diese dieses fleisch
lasse jetzt einfach kurz stehen im
kühlschrank deckt es kurz ab damit sie
bisschen durchziehen kann und dann werde
ich die fleischstücke aufspießen und
dann dürfen sie schon wechselt wenn das
fleisch dürfte auch gerne über nacht
einwirken lassen also mit dieser
marinade und jetzt wird es einfach noch
aufgespießt und kann dann gegrillt
werden
passt auf dass ihr da nicht zu viele
fleischstücke auf dem spieß gebt nicht
zu eng aufeinander
die hütchenspieler die braten oder
grillen jetzt einfach auf meinen grill
auf dem spielteppich ja auch gemacht
sag ich ganz schön zu sehen jetzt meine
hähnchenspieße aus und ihr seht ihr
jetzt natürlich eben gesamten mit dem
ganzen anderen grillgut und die
hähnchenspieße schmecken ganz besonders
gut wenn ihr dazu etwas taktik ging
reicht und dass eventuell auch mal wenn
ihr das gerne möchte ich wünsche euch
auf jeden fall ganz viel spaß mein mann
haben das internet der kamera herum
die rezepte gibt's auf der liste auf
main.de ich freue mich wenn ihr die
rezepte teilt und dann bis zum nächsten
mal